hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so as you can see we're
still in a temporary space so thank you
guys so much for bearing with me we're
just a few weeks away from having our
studio ready so I'm very excited about
that and of course for those of you
who've been following me you know that I
talk a lot about intuitive eating but
just because of the way in like the
speed at which my channel has really
been moving I haven't had a chance to do
a deep dive and give you a comprehensive
overview of what intuitive eating
actually is I'm gonna be doing a
intuitive eating series we'll do a deep
dive on the ten principles of intuitive
eating but until then intuitive eating
is a mind-body framework that was
developed by fellow registered
dieticians Evelyn Triple E and Elise
rich so if you guys don't have the
intuitive eating book it is amazing it
will change your life and I've got a
link down below in my description for
you guys to check it out so until then I
want to tackle some of the most common
questions that I've gotten on my channel
when it comes to intuitive eating on a
very top level basis and before I do I
want to acknowledge that there are
really so many better experts when it
comes to intuitive eating out there
particularly those who are in larger
bodies who have lived experience with
weight stigma I recognize that I have so
much privilege to have a voice here on
YouTube however I really think it's
important that we give these people a
voice we listen to their experiences and
learn from their knowledge so I've left
in the description below a list of some
of my favorite intuitive eating experts
and body-positive
advocates so definitely check that out
with that said you guys have all been
asking me specifically about intuitive
eating so the responsible thing for me
to do of course is to answer so here we
go top level basis will intuitive eating
helped me lose weight intuitive eating
is not a weight loss diet let's get that
clear this is not the new keto
so really it's dependent on your
setpoint your current eating patterns
your relationship with food all of that
will determine whether you gain weight
eating intuitively you lose weight
eating intuitively or your rate just
stays the same every situation is so
different and it really comes down to
your current
and your past relationship with food
with dieting with restriction so the
question often really becomes how will
intuitive eating change my restrict and
overeat cycle and ultimately how is that
going to impact my weight does intuitive
eating mean that I can eat fries and
cake and milkshakes all day Air day and
be healthy no not necessarily
intuitive eating like I said is a
mind-body framework there's ten
principles that really build upon one
another the first of which is to reject
the diet mentality once we have stopped
the cycle of restriction and binging and
the associated guilt and shame that
often comes along with it we can start
to learn how to tune into our bodies
hunger and fullness cues and we can
start to incorporate some gentle
nutrition and exercise into the regime
when I say gentle nutrition
I mean honoring our health and taste
buds while feeling our best so for
example a lot of people find when cake
is no longer off-limits it starts to
kind of lose its allure it no longer has
so much power over us meanwhile once
that moral piece is off the table
we start to acknowledge that eating a
more balanced meal that has some
vegetables protein maybe some
slow-burning carbs in there actually
feels way better physically and
emotionally than eating an entire cake
so our blood Sugar's are more steady our
bowel movements are more irregular we
have better concentration a digestion
sleep stress etc so no intuitive eating
is not just promoting us to eat sugar
every single day all day it's about
listening to our body's true needs and
the first step in doing that is to give
up dieting can you eat intuitively if
you are in a larger body or have an
eating disorder I want to first flag
that it's not uncommon for a person in a
larger body to also be struggling with
an eating disorder
you really can't judge a book by its
cover having said that this is why it's
so important to work with an intuitive
eating registered dietician because
everybody's journey is going to look so
different some people especially those
who are starting with the
eating disorder and who have fallen out
of touch with their hunger and fullness
cues may need to work with a registered
dietician on some mechanical eating so
that might be like following a bit of a
meal plan or eating every two to three
hours and once they've achieved that
weight restoration and they're more in
tune with their body's needs then we can
work through and embrace all of the
principles of intuitive eating having
said that I truly believe that intuitive
eating is something that anyone can
eventually achieve and practice and even
if you are having to work through some
mechanical eating at the beginning of
your journey it doesn't preclude you
from working through some of the
principles of intuitive eating so for
example even if you are not ready to
start honoring your hunger or respecting
your fullness you could begin by
rejecting the diet mentality or
challenging the food police for example
why did you say that obesity is a bad
word the word obesity is everywhere in
the medical literature and yes it is an
official medicalised term however
there's a lot of reasons why some people
find it derogatory and stigmatizing the
origin of the word itself feels
insensitive in that it is literally
translated to mean to eat oneself fat
second pathologizing someone's body
shape just perpetuates weight stigma and
reduces a person's identity to their
body weight this is why the medical
community is moving towards person first
language when discussing a person and
their illness so for the same reason
when I was in school to become a
dietician we were just being taught to
no longer use the term diabetic and
instead use the words person with
diabetes so as not to label somebody as
their disease for those of you guys who
have a bit of a tough love approach you
should know that shaming somebody for
their weight is actually
counterproductive evidence actually
suggests that people are more likely to
engage in healthy behaviors when they're
encouraged to achieve a healthy weight
rather than be called obese I am NOT in
a larger body so as an ally really my
job is to listen and if people who have
experienced this weight stigma feel that
terms like fat or larger body are less
stigmatizing to them
the least I can do as an ally is to just
respect that I feel addicted to food how
can I possibly engage in intuitive
eating I have an entire video about food
addiction coming up where I do a really
good deep dive so stay tuned for that
but I want to first say that I probably
often oversimplify the experience of
intuitive eating and it probably feels
like I'm being super flippant about it
for those of you who are feeling so out
of touch and far away from this as a
reality but I absolutely empathize with
the feeling of being addicted to food
that is real true lived experience and
I'm not going to dismiss that I may come
from a North or Exia background
but when I was really in the throes of
my eating disorder my restriction was
often coupled with these immense intense
binges often eating large amounts of
food that I didn't even like in line
with my experience however the evidence
suggests that food addiction behaviors
are actually only evident in times of
restriction in other words you feel out
of control with food as a result of a
history or current experience of
restriction and dieting dieting causes
an unhealthy obsession around food and
this experience can actually mitigate it
with intuitive eating and yes when you
start intuitive eating you're probably
going to find that it's been restricting
certain foods or quantity of foods
you're gonna go overboard and eat these
foods in excess totally normal
however this phase is generally pretty
short-lived it really depends on how
long you've been dieting or how extreme
the restriction has been so once you
start to trust that the foods you love
are not going to be followed by
abstinence you can start to eat in a
healthier kind of happier more balanced
way there is power in permission I know
I'm being briefed on this but I'm going
to go into way more detail in my
intuitive eating series very soon if
intuitive eating does not result in
weight loss what's the point well I've
already mentioned that intuitive eating
may cause you to lose weight and may
cause you to gain weight maybe your
weight will stay the exact same all
depending on your set point and your
eating
your relationship with food however
intuitive eating has a ton of really
important health benefits that should
not be dismissed
research suggests that intuitive eating
may improve cholesterol levels improve
blood pressure improve blood sugar
better body image higher self-esteem
improve your metabolism decrease rates
of disordered and emotional eating
decrease stress levels and increase
satisfaction with life you can
experience all of these things and not
drop a pound which is why weight is not
always the best indicator of health one
systematic review found that health at
every size interventions that focused on
intuitive eating healthy eating
behaviors and physical activity had
better health outcomes than restrictive
diets that focused only on weight loss
one of the biggest benefits of intuitive
eating is that it helps improve your
relationship with food when you tune in
to your body you start to recognize how
certain foods or quantities of food make
you feel both emotionally and physically
and you also kind of get more in tune
with whatever you like and dislike this
is a long-term process for a lifelong
benefit it is not a quick fix or a fad
isn't being obese bad for your health
don't these people need to lose weight
first of all I know we see a lot of
headlines and research linking higher
weights to disease however it's really
important that we distinguish between
correlation which is what that is and
causation which we can't prove there is
a growing number of studies out there
suggesting that healthy behaviors not
body weight alone is a bigger
contributing factor so for example a
meta-analysis found that including more
fruits veggies and fiber in your diet
reduce the risk of diabetes and improved
blood sugar blood pressure and
cholesterol levels even when no weight
loss occurred there are also a lot of
challenges that people in larger bodies
experience that may explain some of
these disparities for one there's the
problem of weight cycling or yo-yo
dieting which is very common among
people in larger bodies who are
constantly on and off weight loss diets
research has found that when people lose
weight and regain weight and lose weight
again which is what yo-yo dieting or
weight cycling is that process increases
the risk of
zees and now the process is pretty much
inevitable just based on what we know
about set point theory and weight loss
prevention mechanisms that go on in the
body so for example one study found that
larger body women who died it had high
blood pressure where larger body women
who never dieted had normal blood
pressure in other words it seems that
it's the dieting and the associated
weight cycling that puts a person at
higher risk of health issues like
hypertension rather than the static body
weight alone second there's the issue of
weight stigma people often think that
telling a fat person to lose weight is
motivating but often it actually has the
opposite effect research suggests that
people who experience weight
discrimination have twice the
physiological stress as people who don't
and that stress is associated with type
2 diabetes hypertension and heart
disease
research on weight stigma has also shown
that people who have been fat shamed are
less likely to engage in behaviors that
improve their health because they're
less likely to go to the doctors or
engage in physical activity and they're
more likely to overeat this is
particularly troubling in the medical
community as research has suggests that
weight bias among doctors has the power
to cause binge eating disorder lower
motivation for exercise increased blood
pressure and blood sugar less trust in
our health care providers and a reduced
engagement with health care services
leading to advanced or poorly controlled
chronic disease and low quality of life
on the flip side research suggests that
when people are supported and they feel
secure and comfortable in their own skin
they're more likely to make healthy
behavior choices and put their health
first regardless of the number on the
scale third there's also the social
determinants of health which
significantly influence the health of
populations so these range between
personal social economic environmental
factors I mean some of the big ones are
things like income or social status
education or employment all of which
play major roles in explaining some of
these health disparities so while we
can't always control these social
factors and we definitely can't control
genetics
I believe we really should be focusing
on what we can control and that is our
behavior how has thin privilege real
when you workout and eat healthy and a
fat person does not then privilege is
not about how much exercise a person
does to maintain their physique also
isn't the idea that thin people are not
gonna get body shame for being too small
and therefore never experience body
image issues or body shaming I mean we
are all susceptible to that it's simply
an acknowledgment that having a socially
accepted body affords you benefits
access and less discrimination in a
society that larger body folks just
don't have like the idea that any
clothing store is gonna carry my size
and an airline seat is always gonna fit
my body or even just equal access to
employment or healthcare I mean there
are all sorts of privileges in our life
that we really should be reflecting on
between white privilege and heterosexual
privilege and gender privilege etc I'm
not gonna push further on that but I'm
going to leave you with this amazing
quote from Cora Harrington from a
lingerie addict definitely check out her
entire kind of tweet series on thin
privilege it's pretty much gold does
health at every size mean you can gain
as much weight as you want or lose as
much weight as you want and be healthy
not necessarily so first I want to
reiterate that the term is health at
every size not healthy at every size I
know it's subtle but it's different
second the health and every size
philosophy simply acknowledges that
well-being and healthy behaviors are
more important than the number on the
scale Linda Bacon's book is amazing it's
a great place to start so I've linked
that below but basically there's five
principles the first of which is that no
body weight should be pathologized
well I know a lot of you guys are
probably thinking well what about
somebody who's 70 pounds and anorexic or
500 pounds and bedridden and respond I
would quote size diversity and Health's
website which states phase shifts the
focus to acknowledging and respecting an
individual circumstances and works to
investigate and support options that are
available to help make choices that
benefit health and well-being
in both of these circumstances using a
haze approach puts the focus on their
behaviors unique sets of abilities and
available resources and places them in
the context of their life as the primary
areas of concern and consideration the
haze framework is based on research that
suggests that weight loss diets just
don't work and through the restrict and
binge cycle that we've talked about they
often can actually result in more weight
gain haze also points to research
suggesting that yo-yo dieting and weight
stigma to experiences that are very
common with people in larger bodies can
often explain health disparities finally
haze is grounded in the evidence that
suggests that a person's body weight and
size and shape is not a great predictor
of their health so for example a 2012
study found that there were four
behaviors associated with a reduced risk
of mortality including lots of fruits
and vegetables in your diet regular
exercise moderate alcohol intake and
reducing or quitting smoking
none of which included specifically
having to manipulate or change your body
shape size or weight these are behaviors
that ultimately we can control
furthermore a series of randomized
control trials found that a haze
approach was better associated with
improvements in blood lipids and blood
pressure when compared with a weight
loss treatment so haze is not just about
telling everybody hey you just go be fat
but rather it's about shifting the focus
away from the pursuit of being just one
socially desirable body shape and size
and instead towards the pursuit of
healthy behaviors like eating a
well-balanced diet physical activity
sleep stress management and intuitive
eating all while working together with
your body's natural shape and size
regardless of where it falls on the
scale
are you a hazed dietician I know this is
controversial so I will just say this I
am a hey supporter and a haze learner
I'm not a haze expert you can check out
my list of resources below for people
who are way more versed than I am and I
too am really just trying to sort
through all the research and evidence to
make on its sense of it all
I do believe the research linking body
weight to disease is flawed correlation
based and therefore very difficult to
tease apart from behaviors I also think
that the research supporting Hayes is
promising and convincing to me that
behaviors do play a large role however
the research in Hayes is really in its
infancy so it's not extensive enough to
be able to explain everything yet what I
know for sure is that the world would be
better without dieting we likely
wouldn't see our body weight increasing
way beyond our natural setpoint
aka gaining a lot of weight we wouldn't
be obsessing over sugar and we wouldn't
be feeling like we're addicted to food
or shaming ourselves or others over our
body or behaviors we would probably be a
much healthier society both physically
and emotionally everyone's journey is
different and I'm not discounting that
weight loss may or may not be part of
that journey but I just want to make
sure that our next generation doesn't
make the same mistakes that we have I
want to end this video by saying I know
that sometimes I'm a little bit harsh
when it comes to calling out diet
culture or you tubers kind of gaps in
their diet or their relationship with
food and because food is so emotional
that I can sometimes offend people I
apologize for that you should know that
I believe it makes total sense that you
want to lose weight we live in a society
that is completely obsessed with a
specific body shape and size and being
thin affords you so many luxuries in
that environment I admit that even I'm
not immune to this I have body
insecurities thoughts all the time but
while I was on vacation I was doing a
lot of reading and podcast listening and
I da ting and I want to emphasize that
here at Abby's kitchen you are welcome
everyone is welcome you know I was
listening to an amazing podcast by
Christi Harrison who is the best so
check out her podcast got a link to it
below but basically one thing she said
was that even though if you were auntie
it doesn't mean we are anti dieter
in other words you can sit with us
you're welcome if you're pursuing weight
loss you're welcome if you're vegan
you're welcome if you're paleo or keto
whatever you do you if you're eating in
a way that feels good to you then
amazing but unless you are a
professional keep your agenda to
yourself further the main reason why I
call these things out so loudly on my
channel here is not to undermine
people's body autonomy but only to
actually change the overwhelming social
pressure that we feel to police and
alter our bodies I need you to
understand that it doesn't matter what
your favourite youtuber is doing it
doesn't matter what foods are cutting
out or how much or how little they're
eating that is not the only way to be
healthy only you know what your body
really needs you don't need to change
your body and really nobody should be
telling you that you do I'm gonna be
diving into this in way more detail in
my intuitive eating series so stay tuned
for that but until then I'm simply
trying to dispel myths denounce Thai
culture in general and neutralize the
language we use around food so guys I
hope this answered a little bit of your
questions gave you a bit of a teaser
please know that this is by no means
extensive so I highly recommend getting
the intuitive eating book that I'm
linking below that will really get you
started and if you like this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with things that you want
me to cover in the intuitive eating
series subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]